the final measure I'm announcing today  has never been tried in the UK before  this moment is unique we need to be  creative so to get customers back into  restaurants cafes and pubs and protect  the 1.8 million people who work in them  I can announce today that for the month  of August we will give everyone in the  country and eat out to help out discount  meals eaten at any participating  business monday to wednesday will be 50%  off up to a maximum discount of 10  pounds per head for everyone including  children businesses will need to  register I can do so through a simple  website open next Monday each week in  August businesses can then claim the  money back with the funds in their bank  account within 5 working days 1.8  million people were in this industry  they need our support and with this  measure we can all eat out to help out  [Applause]